DON'T EXPECT EVERYTHING TO BE
SOLVED AT THE END OF THIS
MEETING BUT WE THINK IT IS IN
OUR INTEREST TO HAVE THE
MEETING, WHICH IS WHY WE
PROPOSED IT TO THE PRESIDENT.
>> WERE THERE ANY PRECONDITIONS?
>> NO.
>> Bret: WELL, THEY WILL BE
MEETING IN GENEVA IN A FEW
WEEKS.
THE PRESIDENT ON THE WAY OUT
MARINE ONE ALSO SAID IT WAS TOO
LATE FOR THE NORD STREAM 2
SANCTIONS TO TAKE PLACE.
HE SAID THE PIPELINE WAS ALMOST
COMPLETED BY THE TIME HE TOOK
OFFICE AND IT WOULD BE COUNTER
PRODUCTIVE TO SAY THAT EUROPEAN
RELATIONS WOULD BE AFFECTED.
I'M AGAINST IT BUT IT'S TOO
LATE, ESSENTIALLY IS WHAT HE
SAID.
BUT, THERE IS AN ELECTION IN
GERMANY COMING UP.
AND THE LEADING GROUP THAT
POSSIBLY COULD WIN TAKING OVER
FOR CHANCELLOR ANGELA MERKEL IS
A GREEN PARTY THAT'S OPPOSED TO
THAT PIPELINE.
BEN, THIS IS AN INTERESTING PLAY
AS RUSSIA CONTINUES TO POKE THE
U.S.
>> AN INTERESTING PLAY.
I THINK IT'S A DISAPPOINTING
PLAY IN A LOT OF DIFFERENT WAYS.
I CAN ONLY IMAGINE WHAT THEN
CANDIDATE JOE BIDEN WOULD BE
SAYING IF THEN PRESIDENT TRUMP
HAD BEEN ENGAGED IN A LOT OF
THESE DIFFERENT ACTIVITIES THAT
ARE ESSENTIALLY PLAYING VERY
SOFTLY WITH RUSSIA.
I'M GOING TO BE CURIOUS ABOUT A
NUMBER OF THINGS COMING OUT OF
THIS MEETING.
ONE OF THE BIG THINGS I WILL BE
PAYING ATTENTION TO THE SUBJECT
OF ALEXA NAVALNY IS BROUGHT UP.
TO ME THAT'S SUBJECT ANY
DISCUSSION WITH VLADIMIR PUTIN
REGARDLESS OF ANYTHING ELSE ON
THE TABLE BECAUSE OF THAT
IMPORTANCE OF THAT ISSUE.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE IF
JOE BIDEN DOES THAT.
>> Bret: CHARLIE?
>> YOU KNOW, IT'S JUST AMAZING,
YOU KNOW, THE BOTTOM LINE HERE
IS JOE BIDEN MIGHT BE AGAINST
THE PIPELINE IN EUROPE BUT HE
GREEN LIGHTED IT AND, OF COURSE,
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES, THE
FIRST THING HE DID, ONE OF HIS
FIRST ACTIONS AS PRESIDENT WAS
TO KILL A PIPELINE IN THE UNITED
STATES.
WHO IS HE WORKING FOR?
I DON'T KNOW.
>> Bret: THE -- WELL, TAKE A
LISTEN TO CRITICISM OF THIS
SUMMIT, HAROLD.
>> RUSSIA IS -- TRIED TO POKE
THE UNITED STATES IN THE EYE
EVERY DAY THEY CAN.
SO, HE IS A THUG.
HE IS NOT A FRIEND.
YOU KNOW, IT WOULD BE NICE IF
SOMETHING COULD HAPPEN OUT OF
IT.
>> WE MAY HAVE FORGOTTEN OVER
THE PAST COUPLE OF YEARS BUT
THIS IS HOW DIPLOMACY WORKS.
WE DON'T MEET WITH PEOPLE ONLY
WHEN WE AGREE.
IT'S ACTUALLY IMPORTANT TO MEET
WITH LEADERS WHEN WE HAVE A
RANGE OF DISAGREEMENTS AS WE DO
WITH RUSSIAN LEADERS.
SO, WE DON'T REGARD THE MEETING
WITH THE RUSSIAN PRESIDENT AS A
REWARD.
WE REGARD IT AS A VITAL PART OF
DEFENDING AMERICA'S INTEREST.
>> Bret: FOR ALL THE YEARS OF
DEMOCRATS CRITICIZING PRESIDENT
TRUMP FOR BEING WHAT THEY SAID
WAS TOO CLOSE TO RUSSIA OR
SOMEHOW BEING A RUSSIAN AGENT,
IT DOES SEEM LIKE THE POLICIES
OF THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION ARE
A LITTLE SOFTER THAN WHAT THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WAS TO
RUSSIA.
>> I WOULD DIFFER THERE I THINK
THIS PRESIDENT, NO PRESIDENT IN
MY LIFETIME HAS BROUGHT MORE
EXPERIENCE WITH EXCEPTION OF
POSSIBLY PRESIDENT GEORGE H.W.
BUSH AROUND FOREIGN POLICY THAN
THIS PRESIDENT.
HE HAS BEEN BLUNT.
HE HAS BEEN SERIOUS.
HE HAS BEEN FORTH RIGHT, AND HE
HAS BEEN TRANSPARENT ABOUT WHAT
HE WANTS TO GET DONE HERE.
LOOK, I THINK BEN IS RIGHT HE
HAS TO RAISE THE NAVALNY ISSUE
I'M SURE THE PRESIDENT.
WILL PRESIDENT BIDEN ALSO KNOWS
THAT PRESIDENT PUTIN IS FACING
JOBLESSNESS AND CORRUPTION
THAT'S ABOUND IN THE COUNTRY.
HE WILL BE BLUNT WITH HIM.
PRESIDENT BIDEN ALSO KNOWS THAT
OUR REAL ADVERSARY OF THE 2
ISst CENTURY ENGAGEMENT WITH
CHINA.
I HAVE GREAT CONFIDENCE THAT THE
PRESIDENT WILL FIND THE RIGHT
TONE, THE RIGHT TEMPERAMENT AND
MORE IMPORTANTLY THE RIGHT
SUBSTANTIVE BLUNTING OF RUSSIA
IN THIS MEETING IN GENEVA.
>> Bret: THERE IS QUESTIONS
ABOUT CHINA AS WELL WHETHER HE
HAS THE SAME TALKING POINTS
THERE ON THAT FRONT AS WELL.
OKAY, PANEL, STA